[Music]
they freaked out from takeoff to landon
because he said let's go brandon it's
the one lgb that left hates to see
that's cute
southwest airlines will conduct an
internal investigation into a pilot who
finished his passenger greeting with the
phrase let's go brandon which sounded
fine to me since 89 percent of male
flight attendants are named brandon
you can look it up
it all started after an ap reporter on
the flight tweeted about the remark
which quickly had all the grouches
fainting on their couches cnn's asha
rangapa made this bold point quote i'd
love for a southwest pilot to say long
live isis before taking off my guess is
that one the plane would be immediately
grounded two the pilot fired and three a
statement issued by the airline within a
matter of hours
well
it's a bad comparison
it just is a bad comparison
especially since no one has helped isis
more than joe biden
two laughs out of one joke
but if someone equates jokes with
torture terror and murder it can only
mean one thing they've been watching the
colbert show
of course southwest apologized adding
southwest does not condone employees
sharing their personal political
opinions while on the job serving our
customers it's funny though the left has
been doing this for years joking
publicly about the sitting president
they interrupted their own performance
of hamilton to ambush mike pence there's
thousands of other examples during the
trump era where people loudly voiced
their trump hate in public and remember
american airlines allowing employees to
wear blm pins but now when non-libs or
righties are doing it they left the left
is saying hey that's not fair i wonder
what the man himself thinks of all this
look look look they told me i can't talk
about brandon
i'm gonna get in trouble here talking
about brandon
but i want to talk about him
let's go brandon let's go brandon i
never seen the guy he's afraid of me
i'll tell you something i want to take
him out back behind him
i'll give him one of my
five finger discounts
that's right
let's go brandon that's what it kind of
it's got a different meaning now then
let's go brandon
i could probably do more push-ups
than you and all your cousins
tammy i i don't think that this in my
opinion has nothing to do with the
president it's how the left isn't able
to handle this and they could take a
page out of any conservative or
libertarian's book we've been dealing
with this crap for years yeah and so
much more direct whether it's de niro at
the tonys using the f-word
you know obviously
the beheading of the president that
shakespeare in the park here with
president trump being killed
they can't handle it they can't handle
it and what's funny though is and what i
adore about conservatives
this is like as dramatic as the
conservatives can get is finding a
phrase and using a phrase that sounds
like an insult and sort of is and
they're getting away with it yeah that's
what i love and it's true it's it's true
but what i feel for is for every dad out
there with a kid named brandon who plays
sports yeah
that's my concern every single parent
who can't yell now for their go brandon
it's like
yeah oh
what no i didn't mean it
that is a problem oh don't go for it
brandon
i know the parents care about this yeah
it's it's there's probably about 20
million kids named brandon i would
imagine totally i haven't done the math
on it cap you're that's your department
right that's okay
work something up for tomorrow okay just
leave it on my desk okay all right get
right on that yeah what do you uh what
do you make of this story is it like
he's shouting isis no because the plane
landed
[Laughter]
it's true
yeah it's not the same thing but a lot
of feelings were hurt when that plane
landed
like all my favorite is that people were
saying they're gonna boycott southwest
because there might be
one employee who maybe doesn't like joe
biden like if that's the case you
probably have a lot of stuff to boycott
yeah good luck you know growing your own
food and making your clothes out of
leaves yeah
yeah the upside you'll just be able to
eat ben and jerry's non-stop yeah
morning noon and night that's all you
can eat it's called the joe mackey diet
oh i'm kidding you're in great shape joe
i was just feeding off your your donut
thing i wish
[Laughter]
do you feel like there's a cultural
shift going on joe the people that are
the whiner it used to be the the
republican conservative they were the
stiff people but now it's completely
shift the stiff people are on the left
yeah what happened to liberals man they
used to be cool
like
i remember reading that they they banned
selling candy at the registers in
berkeley and i'm like man you can't even
have candy
i would i wouldn't last a day in that
town
but i'll tell you what i do agree with
liberals that i don't want to hear a
pilot's political opinion i don't want
to hear it at a football game let's not
turn everything into something political
like an award show or public school yeah
i just
i just want to hear
i just want to hear all the pertinent
information to me i don't care that
there's some clouds over the midwest or
we're flying at 40 000 feet that
information doesn't help me at all
just
just be like hey the engine looked good
and we remembered the gas
i do like it when they say
uh aside from a little bumps it's gonna
be smooth i love hearing that when they
do it's gonna be a little bumpy but then
it's gonna be smooth that's the stuff i
like to hear well i think the flight
attendants like really over dramatize
the turbulence so they don't have to be
quick with the drink service
i agree i agree
emily um what do you think of this
okay so i talked to a southwest pilot
and he told me and i was basically like
what would happen if the pilot said
something else political like whatever
something that wasn't this phrase blm
sure and he said well he'd probably or
she would get a stern talking to but
remember they have union backing and
this isn't about safety so he said
there's absolutely no way they'd
probably get time off and then he said
but in this situation because now
southwest is launching this
investigation and they're likely
capitulating to all of this up war that
he'll probably be terminated but then he
said but then he'll get his job back
because he's union-backed and because
they actually can't fire him about it so
i feel like this entire thing is an
illustration of what matters to these
people which is number one not
understanding reality remember when we
lost double digits of pilots in the
coved pandemic and afterwards there was
no flights happening and everyone
freaked out so here though they want to
put him on the chopping block just
because he said something funny and then
secondly the fact that all they want to
do is check that box oh we let him go
even though they're going to bring him
back in through the back door afterwards
interesting exactly well yeah exactly
exactly
you got to move on but don't you
remember southwest was the fun airline
they were always like joking around yeah
they started every flight with a joke
and
i'm from los angeles and it was kind of
irritating because you wanted the flight
to be serious yeah and you thought oh my
god it's the clown car yeah they would
always do they were doing like they were
doing like open mic stuff yes yes i
remember sitting in the eye and they're
doing open mic and it's like what the
hell is going on now it's like you know
can't do that anymore lost their sense
of humor exactly somewhere in the skies
the unfriendly sky see what i did there
i bet i'm the first person to ever say
that certainly yes
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else